so this is an IP I thought notebook
based tutorial and you're definitely
going to want to walk along with all the
coding and everything that we're doing
so I'm gonna give everybody a few
minutes to download that from the URL
above there and then there's a set of
dependencies if you've installed
anaconda you'll definitely have all of
them
it's just numpy Syfy and matplotlib
otherwise so I'm gonna give everybody a
couple minutes to do that then I'm gonna
get right into the right into the talk
and don't worry about the wallet text
it's kind of dual purpose I made it so I
can set it up online you're not gonna
have to read that I'm gonna be talking
during this so I yeah feel free to uh
download it and just make sure you can
run everything oh that's a great
question at two point seven all right
does anybody need a few more minutes you
get started with the ipython notebook or
are we good to go anyone having any
trouble with it all right quiet cloud
kid so my mic is working work correct
okay perfect
all right so let's get started first a
little bit about me my name is Cody I'm
currently working at Netflix on the
real-time analytics team and that
basically means that I do different
analytics in real time the Netflix to
support operations so server outlier
detection is a great example of that we
recently did a blog post on the tech
blog basically any kind of analytic that
you execute in real time that somebody
in Netflix could exploit to improve the
reliability of the service that's that
kind of work falls on me and a co-worker
of mine and change detection happens to
be one of those things and I'll get into
how we use it in a bit but first I'm
going to talk about the problem space so
real time change detection is perhaps
unsurprisingly the process of detecting
change in data streams in real time and
the objective of this tutorial as it
says here is to get you from zero to
being capable of detecting change and
potentially implementing your
Solutions there's so many different ways
you can go at this problem and I've
chosen a select few simple ways to cover
in this in this tutorial but you can
imagine there's probably an infinite
number of ways to solve this problem and
we'll talk about a few of the more
advanced ones that I couldn't get into
at the end of this but in the meantime
we'll be covering like I said some
simple techniques but first let's let's
come up with a formal definition of our
problem since that's kind of the first
thing that we do when we attempt to
solve problems like this so if we have
an unordered or sorry an ordered
incoming stream of observations at
discrete time intervals and we can
imagine that there's some sort of
underlying generating mechanism that's
generating these observations whether
this is you know the microphone that I'm
speaking into right now for example or
the temperature sensor on the CPU in
your laptop all these all kinds of
different things can be generating the
observations that we're seeing and the
thing about these observations are while
they're coming from the generating
mechanism they don't necessarily
perfectly represent the state of the
mechanism there's noise and you know for
example the temperature sensor on your
laptop's processor is producing readings
and we're hoping that they're accurate
but it is not necessarily precisely the
temperature of your processor so the
problem of detecting change then is
simply inferring from the observation
stream if there's been a fundamental
change to the underlying generating
mechanism so in this case as a
temperature increased or am I saying
something different into this microphone
for example so in this tutorial for
practical purposes we're just going to
generate some synthetic data and and
we'll use that to do majority of our
analysis but if also brought some data
that we captured at Netflix and this is
this is real data that this or at least
algorithms like this had to detect and
catch a problem
we'll talk a little bit more about the
data a little further down in the
tutorial but the objective here is
essentially to explore online techniques
which operate on data streams that we've
not yet completely captured so you know
the fact that we're generating data or
running batch analysis here doesn't mean
that these techniques don't work
on live streaming data and in fact we're
gonna fake the streaming in this
tutorial so a great example of change
detection in an offline fashion anyway
has anyone read Bayesian methods for
hackers can I get a show of hands okay
so that's a Cam's book I don't know if
he's in the room I know he's attending
the conference anyway in Bayesian
methods for hackers cam provides a
sequence of observations that are his
daily texting counts and he attempts to
determine if this texting habits have
changed over the course of it says the
month here but it's about 75 days from
the looks of it so I shamelessly stolen
the image from Kemp's book and
essentially the the problem that he
solves in his book is determining
whether or not later in the month he had
different texting habits in the start of
the month and it's a bit difficult to
tell visually but he determines in the
book that he does in fact have different
texting habits in fact he finds he
estimates distributional parameters for
both stages as well as probabilities for
which day it's switched on so uh our
analysis will be similar to that but
again it's streaming we don't have the
whole window to look at we can't try and
pick a point somewhere in the middle and
in this and this analysis here I think
it ended up being around day 45 but we
don't have the luxury of being able to
do that we were observing our sequences
one at a time and we want to trigger an
alert as soon as possible when we've
detected change so here's some good
examples how this might manifest itself
in data we've got some relatively
well-behaved data stream here and at
some point the standard deviation of
this stream increases quite a bit
although you'll notice that the the mean
of the stream is still relatively the
same and that's important later because
this is one class of problem that we'll
find and of course the inverse of this
as well and finally perhaps the more
familiar mean shift where the actual
mean or behavior of the data changes
fundamentally so where might you find
this useful well I gave a couple of
examples earlier but basically any
metric on which you'd want to be alerted
on
this might be effective something that
should stay relatively constant like a
server room temperature for example
although a threshold might be more
appropriate in that case is this here
but or something that drifts over time
such as like your signups for our for a
small startup for example and how I use
this in Netflix is it it's part of a
larger analytic suite so often times you
know you can ask for some sort of
analytic and you know and it with has
this metric changed but one of the
places where it's just used directly is
the call center at Netflix so we had get
you know a certain number of calls per
day saying a device doesn't work and
there's the generating mechanisms
obviously the behavior of that device
and if that changes fundamentally
fundamentally that probably means that
there's a problem with the device so
here's an example of a specific device
and the volume of calls at Netflix you
can imagine that right around the 600
mark there was probably a problem with
that device and after we go through
everything here we'll we'll get to
tackling this data set and see if that
we were able to detect that or see if we
were capable of detecting that but
before we do let's talk about a couple
of challenges here these are these terms
probably aren't very unfamiliar they're
probably fairly familiar if if you do
any sort of work with data but false
positives is a big one especially if if
you're alerting people you know if
you're waking people up in the middle of
the night you false-positive something
you're gonna want to consider and try
and minimize you don't want to wake
somebody up for effectively nothing
people quickly learn to ignore your
alerts false negatives is the opposite
and this is sometimes a bit less serious
but failing to detect something can also
be a big deal and then detection lag
because the ops people that I work with
are constantly pushing me to detect
things quicker making my job difficult
so as we move along with this tutorial
we're gonna implement a handful of
components to support this framework or
to support this problem we're going to
write a detector framework
a simulation framework will talk about
some evaluation functions and then will
implement to change detectors and we're
not going to implement the one I wanted
to because I realized that it might be a
bit a bit much for a two hour tutorial
so there's a quick tutorial schedule and
you can take a look at it there I don't
know how well I'll stick to that but if
I could get everybody to run the the
import so in there and just make sure
that you're you're importing everything
correctly and that you don't get any
errors just put your mouse in there and
press control enter and I'll give
everybody a couple minutes before I move
into the the first topic to make sure
that you're capable of importing
everything and if you if you can't feel
free to put your hand up and I can come
around and give you a hint as best I can
although you're probably just as good at
solving the problem as I am this is
seriously the quietest talk crowd I've
ever had I've either got to get bored to
death or just ready to move along and
it's probably the former alright so uh
let's talk a little bit about data um so
a typical concern when you're working
with streaming algorithms as I might
have mentioned earlier is data
collection so if you've if you've ever
attempted to build or acquire a large
well curated data set you'll quickly
realize it's super expensive both in
terms of time and money I learned this
when working in academia I think I had
data sets of about you know four or five
megabytes and you know that was I guess
not necessarily large but tough to get
your hands on now in the industry I mean
you know if nobody bats an eye if you
have four or five terabytes of data and
one of the bigger problems is unless you
capture that data it might be lost
especially because sometimes you're
streaming the data because it's
expensive to store or because you don't
need to store it so some solutions to
this are to observe the data in the
stream and capture it and we do this
with some data but actually Netflix I
think we store almost everything but we
don't look at it most of the time I
don't know why but anyway and we do have
some we have some stored data here but
that's not really enough to test
you know I can't convince the engineers
to hand tag a ton of data they have
better things to do with their time and
so one of the solutions and I wish I
could have done this when I was in
academia but natural language processing
isn't very amenable to generation but I
figure ass in this case we can create
generators to generate problem sets
where we know the change point because
we've generated it and if you refer back
to our problem definition we're
essentially looking at some sort of
generator that changes so a distribution
that shifts to a different distribution
at some point in time and we can write
generators that will perfectly simulate
this problem and so that that's actually
what we're gonna do here so our base
generator object kind of just lays out
our interface and it's pretty simple
you'll perform some sort of setup in the
initialization if you require any
parameters we'll take it there and then
the get method which takes no parameters
should just return the next data point
in the iteration or in the next data
point in the in the sequence so we're
just going to go through a handful of
generators here I've implemented a bunch
you actually have even the one that
we're going to type in because I
couldn't get the proper multiple screen
setup here so that I can have the
implementation and you know type it out
so but we'll type out the last one
together
so this first distribution generator
that we have essentially just takes a
sci-fi distribution and it's keyword
arguments and returns a random variate
from it during each call to get or I
should have named that next I probably
should have implemented the iterator
interface but uh you know I didn't so in
this case you might ask yourself why is
a single distribution generator useful
when performing change detection well
this is actually really good for
determining when an algorithm might
generate a false positive if this if
your distributions if your entire
generator is drawing on a single
distribution that we know it doesn't
change so you can run your detection
algorithms against that and determine if
it would have produced a false positive
it should essentially generate or it
should essentially detect no change when
with that one and so the next one we
have is a changing distribution
generator and this one's basically the
same concept except for you provide two
distributions two sets of keyword
arguments and a change point and before
a change point will sample the first
distribution and after the change point
will sample the second distribution and
the third one our drift generator was
the one I was going to type in but I
couldn't get the second cleaning screen
experience so it's there if you need to
refer to it but I thought we would live
coded along here to kind of get
everybody involved and let's get people
working with this if anyone has any good
ideas for this as we're typing it out
feel free to just shout it out to me so
and if you don't want to type it in you
actually have it so don't worry about it
if you don't want to and I'm gonna be
talking out loud while we what we do
this but I'm actually going to steal the
comments from this because it's kind of
uninteresting for you guys to type that
in again so with a drift generator
actually I'm gonna do one better so the
problem we're trying to solve with a
drift generator is essentially we want
the same thing as a changing generator
but we don't want it to be abrupt so if
we just jump below here no I have that
twice let's take a generator for a
moment and it's creative changing
distribution generator will do two
normal distributions one with a mean of
three and a standard deviation of one
actually let's go you mean a four
standard deviation 1 and a second one
will go
I mean of ten scale of three let's say
just for fun and at point twenty five
will have it change and then we'll
sample hundred data points from it
perfect so this is what we get with our
changing distribution generator which is
the the one that we're not going to
implement but you'll notice that the
change is very abrupt and often times in
production the type of change you're
trying to detect might not be so let's
say Stark
for example let's say you're monitoring
some metrics related to user interface
and this actually this happens that at
Netflix as well they'll push out a new
version of a user interface but not
every client will pick it up right away
so you're the metric you're monitoring
is going to be some mixture generally
linearly increasing to your new version
but it'll be some mixture of the old
version in the new version generating
the metrics and what we're doing here
with the simulator is we'd like to we'd
like to create a generator that can
generate a similar data stream so
basically one that gradually changes
from the old distribution to the new
distribution by performing a mixture of
the two on this merio sorry if you're
familiar with the the Syfy stats
distributions these are just the keyword
arguments for it but I'll leave it there
for a moment yeah yeah
so generally speaking the office people
like to work with they just like to use
root mean squared error so they should
like to treat false positives and fault
negative false negatives equally I
personally in most streaming algorithms
really prefer a bias against false
positives because I feel like detecting
something and waking somebody up in the
middle of the night is a quick way to
get them to dismiss your work whereas
missing something every now and then is
not quite as serious so I actually don't
have any hard data on it because if we
miss something I might not even know we
missed it but uh as for the the the true
positive rate it seems to be pretty good
it seems to be acceptable for for the
end users so it's tough to gather some
real statistics on it because we tend to
run these over really high high
granularity nargis low granularity and
high dimensionality data sets for
example like I said we we run this
against our devices and we have there
are thousands of devices that stream
Netflix and that this runs against the
large set of them so uh
I mean there might be things that go on
that nobody ever notices so yeah it's
it's very tough to uh tough to get
actual performance metrics but we might
find out later in this tutorial how well
it does against generators alright so if
everyone's ready we'll we'll go ahead
and implement the drift generator
although I'm actually going to hadn't
written that out but I'm actually going
to copy our changing distribution
generator because it's so similar and
I'm just going to paste it right over
here
can everyone still read that can anyone
not read that no okay
I guess you must you have it on your
laptop so in this case all we want to do
is essentially we want a number of time
steps for which this distribution should
drift over to the new version instead of
in to the new distribution instead of
just abruptly changing over so I'm just
going to add a parameter called steps
and we will make steps a member variable
are of our class as well and there's one
other thing we're gonna need and that
that's some sort of a change gradient
for shifting over to the new
distribution so I'm going to create that
as well and all we're going to do is
take a linear space between 0 and 1 over
the number of steps we need and we're
just going to use basically create a
mixture there so if we so if we just go
down to our get method here prior to the
change point we just want to return the
first distribution but then if we're at
if our current position is C here
greater than the change point and less
than the change
change point plus step of steps so if we
haven't completely passed the gradient
yet then we would like to figure out
what that is so self dot change gradient
at self dot position let's see yeah what
am I trying to do I don't have it down
here so rights - self that change point
so how far into the change point are we
will set that to a beta variable and
then all we're going to do is return a
mix of what we had before 1 minus beta
times our first distribution plus beta
times our second distribution which is
just our old return or a lower return
value there that should have worked
yes so I'll give everyone a moment to
finish typing that and then we'll head
back down to the lower cell there and
we'll play around a fit and kind of see
the difference and actually well
everyone's typing that we have one more
generator type which is just a data back
generator it's gonna load a CSV file or
it's gonna take a vector basically and
and just replay it for us in a streaming
fashion so that we can we can test our
algorithms against the captured data
and if anyone's wondering what I did
there I just deleted the old version of
the code there you should still have
that
all right so if we instantiate a version
of our drift generator and you know
let's say we'll move to I change to the
second distribution to a mean of 20 so
we can get kind of a more easy to see
representation there and it looks like I
have an off by one error I do to you
so now we're generating distributions
that shift gradually from one to the
other so we're able to kind of model the
types of problems we might see in the
real world here which is the entire
point of our synthetic data generation
and we're able to model constant data
streams as well using the distribution
generator so with with that we can
generate data streams and we might spend
five or ten minutes playing lifted here
I can come around and help anybody who
has any trouble you can give it a shot
try and generate this line or you know a
line like this line a randomly generated
similar line and that's the first
component we need before we move on to
evaluation which is just a quick section
and we'll get right into the change
detectors this is anybody having any
trouble with the the drift generator
no okay I'll give her everybody a minute
or two to play with that and then I move
on
yep
nothing I had originally intended to
have one as a reference and typed the
other one in but then I I added them
into the the code so that people
couldn't type the motor couldn't figure
it out could have them and and whatnot
they are identical or at least they
should be okay in the in the get method
here when I was selecting bata I had a
subtract one right at the end here and I
was getting it off by one error so I
would get one completely from the new
distribution and you'd have a big spike
yeah everyone get to move along okay so
show of hands here who's familiar with
lost functions there I go a few more
people than the last show of hands
question so we need some technique for
quantifying the performance or we need a
method for quantifying the performance
of our techniques here and what this
will do is allow us to objectively
compare two techniques we can say one's
better than the other because it
generates less loss so again if you're
unfamiliar with with loss functions it's
actually an excellent introduction to
them in in chapter 5 of cams book again
that's the second time I've plugged this
book I think it's the only time only
other time anyway but if you refer back
to the challenges in our introduction
this is actually next is an opportunity
to express a preference for some
particular challenge for example if you
prefer to generate false negatives over
false positives so if you'd rather not
be waking people up accidentally in the
middle of the night you can design a
loss function that will penalize false
positives more harshly than false
negatives and we actually do this with
some other algorithms that are unrelated
to this that do things like terminate
servers in our production environment we
will bias it against false positives
because we'd really rather not be
killing perfectly healthy servers anyway
yeah so you might want to look into loss
functions if
if you're interested in evaluating this
on a more in-depth level but we've
stayed pretty simple here so what we'll
be doing is root squared error loss so
we're just taking the the square of the
difference between the known change
point and the point we've detected so if
we detect 5 to 10 time steps early it's
5 squared 25 and then the square root of
that which would be 5 again or if we
detect 5 minutes late
same thing and then we have root mean
squared error loss which is just the
average of that previous metric so again
like I was saying if we're supposed to
detect a point 25 and we detect it point
30 we get five loss same thing if we
detect a point 20 it's five loss and
this is just linearly increasing so we
get one loss for being one point away
this is a fairly straightforward method
you can do things like log loss so that
you're you're penalizing things that are
further away a little less than you
would otherwise
but that's the topic for a different
tutorial so does anyone have any
questions about loss functions it's a
pretty quick topic I didn't really want
to get into it basically the higher the
value the worse that the algorithm did
and our simulator will be designed to
take these loss functions and apply them
to the results of the simulation so that
we can see if one technique is better
than the other No okay so moving on to
the detector scent this is kind of the
meat or the workhorse of this tutorial
and they can be pretty simple or
incredibly complex I really wanted to do
a Bayesian detector for this tutorial
but given that time is kind of flying by
I'm really glad I didn't because it
probably won't take me the whole two
hours to explain it so there's a bunch
of different techniques that we can
utilize to detect this hopefully in
looking at the data that the generator
is generated maybe you've thought of
some we're gonna do two naive
implementations after this first base
detector which is just like the most
incredibly naive thing you can you can
think of which is just going to specify
err interface again so our change the
texture is our change detector is
roughly as simple as a generator here
and all we need to do is record a change
point and then have a step function that
ingests each piece of data decides what
to do with it and then returns whether
or not we've triggered our detection so
if we detect a change we set triggered
to true and we return that and so this
base one here this simply just checks to
see if the same value if the value that
just came in was the exact same as the
last one which is basically never useful
this is a degenerate case of the problem
but you know if you had something that
was not supposed to be all zeros and
then suddenly you've got a value for
example if you were monitoring a
perfectly quiet room with a microphone
or something but even then you're
probably getting a little noise point
being well this does something it does
not do anything useful currently and
just past that we have a simulator which
I won't get into the implementation
details of but the interface is
important we're just going to pass it a
list of generators a detector and then a
quick limit for how many how many data
points that can go on because if you're
change detector never detects any change
you'll want to stop at some point
and then there's a run function which
can plot our results so and again this
is the same thing as the drift detector
here we're gonna there we go I got these
in the wrong order but that's okay so
we're actually going to we're going to
do the threshold detector first so one
of the whenever you kind of do any sort
of anomaly detection or change detection
or anything like that people almost
always immediately want to calculate the
mean and standard deviation and just see
if something fits within some sort of
threshold and we're gonna kind of follow
that vein and and use normal
approximation on the entire data stream
and then on a short window and we're
gonna compare the two and see if
according to our normal approximation
they appear to be from the same
distribution so I'm actually gonna move
this upward because I put these in
backwards
not really a surprise so for those of
you following along we're doing the the
threshold detector first yes so that's
gonna rename the Solem to thresh
detector two so they don't conflict so
the the basic idea
is we're gonna come up with some sort of
a threshold so in this case it'll be
just a ratio threshold so I'm gonna
default this to zero point to you just
like we did below and so basically all
we're gonna all we're gonna be doing is
trying to detect if this if our smaller
more recent window is at least 20%
bigger in the cases or 0.2 then our than
our entire estimation for the
distribution we're gonna use well for
its method is anyone familiar with well
for its method for a detector for
estimating mean and standard deviation
no okay so most of the time when you
when you estimate the mean of a
distribution you just sum though up and
divide it by the total number of values
but that requires keeping all the values
around which isn't that useful for
streaming algorithm because you really
don't want to hang on to a potentially
infinite number of numbers so there's
just it's you'll learn it in this
tutorial here it's pretty simple you can
actually see it below if you look down
at the Thresh detector - we use that to
estimate the mean and standard deviation
of the entire stream over the entire
lifetime of the stream and then we'll
keep a very small window around and
we'll compare that to our distributional
estimate of the longer data stream so in
this case we'll also bring we'll also
take a window length I'm going to
default it to 10 and then a minimum
training value which is just the number
of observations we have to have before
we even start guessing that there's
change because as you can imagine these
things generate a lot of false positives
in the early stages before they've
caught on to everything there before
they've had time to learn so we're just
gonna use a double-ended queue for our
window because it has all of the
properties that we'd like and by that I
mean if we append a value past the max
length it'll kick the oldest value out
which is exactly what we want to do for
a sliding window so we'll use a double
into key for a window and then oh oh
there's two and a second type of perfect
thank you
okay so these are these next couple of
variables I'm going to record here are
are used for a wall for its method and
you might find this useful in other in
other fields or other other problems if
you have to estimate the mean and
standard deviation of a distribution and
you can't keep them all around so we're
just going to create a sum sum squared
and then an N to count our number of
observations and that sets up our that
sets up our object so we can actually
just get right into the the step
function we're just going to take our
double and the first thing we're going
to want to do is just append it to our
window and again right at the bottom of
the screen there you can see kind of
everything that we're about to start
doing and again like I said the the
double-ended queue will conveniently
kick out the old values so we don't even
need to worry about that afterward so
we'll just increase our count by one and
then we're gonna add to some the new
datum that we've observed and to sum
squared the square of the new datum and
then I believe we can calculate our mu
just using the self dot sum divided by
self dot and
yes yeah that's what we do down here
right so uh that should be intuitive to
anybody has ever worked with I mean I
imagine most people in this room have if
you have the sum of all the values you
only have to keep around one double
instead of all the doubles and if you
have the count that's all you need so
you can use that to estimate the mean of
any streaming distribution or any any
set of streaming values so if we have
observed more than our minimum training
number then we can go ahead and perform
some form of analysis and I'm just gonna
write past there for now so I can write
it returns self dot yep so underneath
this if statement here this is we're
gonna want to perform the bulk of our
analysis and all we're gonna do is
basically calculate the ratio between
the two and then I'm actually gonna copy
this because it's a long long formula
but look how cute the ratio between the
two and then we'll determine if if we
want to trigger or not so in this case
the variance is calculated just by this
formula which is essentially dividing
the sum squared minus the number of
observations times the mean squared and
then dividing that by one subtracted
from the number of observations that
gets us our variance and then we can get
our standard deviation just by taking
the square root of the variance so now
we can calculate the ratio of the
summary statistics which will be the C
here we'll take the the mean so the sum
of our window divided by the length of
our window
/ our estimated mean so you can imagine
a more intelligent algorithm would
probably want to take the standard
deviation into consideration somehow and
if you if you remember the first the
very first graph I showed up here has
the same mean but two different standard
deviation so if there's obviously been a
change in this in this data set and the
algorithm we've just started to
implement will not be robust against
that case at all which is essentially
why Gaussian approximation for this sort
of thing is a bad idea
or at least a very limited useful very
limited use idea so we're gonna check if
our ratio is greater than 1.0 plus our
threshold or if ratio is less than 1.0
minus our threshold
and if either of these are the case we
can set trigger to true and we'll set
our change point for a simulator to pick
up to the current value there the
current current time step I think it's
everything we need to do all right and I
have a have a note in the old one this
will completely fail if our if our
estimated mean is zero but this is
research code so there's no surprise
that this bugs in it
so I'm gonna give everyone a minute to
finish typing that in and then we'll
play around with it and we can actually
see what this sort of thing can detect
what kind of thing it can't detect and
we'll talk about the drawbacks and then
we'll talk about a second approach does
anyone have any questions no we really
don't actually we only need two we could
do that inside of here
yeah absolutely so if you take a look at
the we're comparing the the mean of
these two distributions and if you take
a look at this there's obviously been a
change at this point here but both of
these behaviors have the same mean so we
won't detect this or at least we're not
likely to detect this we aren't also
comparing variance ah you so like it
like I was saying a more intelligent
technique might want to compare variance
actually calculate the variance in this
but we don't actually
completeness is sake with well fits
method but we don't actually we don't
actually utilize it anywhere any other
questions okay so
let's take another I need to delete this
there we go so let's have some fun with
this threshold detector then and let's
just make sure that I haven't typed it
anything correctly because that's
entirely possible
oh go through threshold the defaults
start yeah I wrote the default for both
and surprisingly it worked okay so let's
take our old generator the one we won
we've created earlier and let's just see
how well it works against this
so our simulator takes the list of
generators and we're just gonna feed the
one right now our detector which it will
clone so you only have to instantiate it
once and then a limit will go with will
go at the default my min 1200 oh right
so if we just call our simulators run
method and we'll set plot to true so we
can see what's going on
you'll notice that we the black bar is
our known change point and the red bar
is our detected change point so this
took us twenty six extra time steps to
detect this change which is kind of poor
but this this boils it down to
essentially a parameter selection
problem so if we if we got more
sensitive say we only wanted Oh
apparently 10% change won't work that
well either
oh right cuz I'm a minimum of fifty
fifty steps for the detection let's push
this out a little more to fifty change
will take a hundred there we go so the
change happens at two fifty and and with
ten percent it actually triggers far too
early so that that's that's roughly a
good at halfway decent parameter set for
this there's a change point at let's
call it two hundred fifty minutes and
this algorithm with the twenty percent
sensitivity in a window size of ten
detects the change at at 11 minutes
after that's two hundred sixty one
minutes which if we can take a look at
what that would look like if let's say
we just increased this decrease the
sensitivity a bunch you'll see that it
starts ramping up really quickly there
so with twenty percent sensitivity we're
actually catching the change really
quickly which would be useful I mean
this this shift here hardly looks like
it's outside the bounds of noise but it
was able to detect it there and I just
got kind of lucky selecting the
parameters there so it's not always that
easy to do
so this is probably a good opportunity
to take a few minutes stop let people
play with the generators some plug-in
the different parameters to the detector
and try out different things with the
generator I'm gonna do the same thing up
here but I'll answer any questions that
anyone has and I'll come around to help
anybody if anyone's having any issues
with it yeah otherwise I would recommend
trying a few different generators even
the distribution generator that doesn't
doesn't change might be a good one to
play with here yeah
that that's a really reasonable question
and it tends to really depend on what
you're doing so we have a tool for
example it's it's called canary analysis
and Netflix that's another one of my
team owns and it's a it kind of treat
some builds as black boxes and
statistically compares the two and
there's a there's a big argument
internally right now as to whether or
not we should include anomalous and
outlying boxes in the analysis because
the fact that they exist says something
about about the data but on the flip
side you're right first assistant will
comparison they really kind of throw
everything off so in this case generally
speaking I would remove them for most
analysis depending what you're doing
like I do another analysis where we
configure networking libraries and
obviously we strip out the anomalies
before configuring a timeout for example
so I'd say whether or not you would
include or not include an anomaly really
depends on the the purpose of the
analysis I mean if they're if their
presence is meaningful in some way to
your analysis then you're probably going
to want to keep them in for example our
the canary analysis right if you're
building more anomalous servers then
that's a piece of information that
people are going to want to know despite
the fact that it throws off the actual
analysis
so I'm just going to make up some some
fake distributions here and and we're
just going to see how well this performs
on all of them and you'll find that a
parameter selection is incredibly
important to this
ok so I just ran it here with four semi
randomly generated distributions all
using our drift generator and you'll
notice a few of them are really close
this one which I guess this is our first
distribution which I changed it detects
it almost immediately we get a false
positive early here this one's fairly
close
looks like about 25 points off and this
one is just way off another early false
positive and we averaged 239 minutes of
error times which is not that great but
so I'm going to keep generating kind of
some fake data sets while you guys play
with that and I'll continue to answer
any questions for the next couple of
minutes then we move on to the second
detector and we'll kind of put the two
against each other and see which one
performs better and then we'll we'll get
into talking about technique techniques
that you actually might want to use
after we go through the case study I've
created for generate four generators
here and they kind of represent our
previous distributions that we looked at
or the types of problems that we might
run into here at least three the low
standard deviation to a high standard
deviation high standard deviation to low
standard deviation and then a mean shift
and you'll notice the mean stays the
same in both of these two and we've run
our simulations against these and so
let's see here our first distribution is
is a low mean low standard deviation to
high mean high standard deviation and
change occurs to 250 and we detected it
almost right away the second one high
center D or high mean high standard
deviation to a low mean low standard
deviation and we detected that almost
right away too so both times the mean
changed and our algorithm that compares
means was able to detect it really
quickly then our third one here is the
one where we just move into a high
standard deviation but the mean doesn't
change at all and the algorithm
completely fails to detect it in fact it
scores 800 points of loss here which is
almost almost all of our average loss
and then in the last function here
we go from a mean of 55 and a standard
deviation of 10 down to 20 and 3 and we
do okay we don't do great but it's a bit
difficult to even see visually so you
can imagine the algorithm kind of
suffers from a similar problem it's the
change is rather subtle and as a result
it takes us a little while to do it
especially because we spend a hundred
and twenty five time steps shifting over
to the new distribution so given that
it's actually it actually did halfway
decently there but oh yeah yeah it is so
in this case it's actually a false
positive slightly early and that might
just be due to the might be on top no
okay yeah yeah that is a false positive
there so that's kind of interesting I'd
be curious to look into why that
happened probably that's true yeah there
we go
problem solved there we go perfect
anyway really similar behavior though
you noticed so this one it detected it's
slightly late this time
but again pretty close completely
dropped the ball on the on the one that
didn't shift the mean even though
visually speaking you can tell that
clearly there was a change in these two
distributions so if everyone is yep
oh sorry can I get you to repeat
yourself so to get sidetracked a little
bit the system I work on it it records
about 1.2 billion unique time series so
usually when when something goes on that
it doesn't catch I don't even know and
that's one of the reasons that we're
creating automated algorithms to kind of
route these problems out and alert us
because plenty of things go by that we
have absolutely no ideas even happened
yeah yeah so I'm on the real-time
analytics team so uh this stuff I do
operates in real time the data science
team stores the data and I'm sure they
find it eventually but uh I maybe I
should open a dialogue with them where
they can they can throw things at me
that I missed all right so we're gonna
move on to the the second change
detector then if everyone is good to
move along and we'll pit the two against
each other afterward I had really wanted
to do a Bayesian change detector but
given that over an hour it's already
passed and really glad I didn't because
depending on your background it may or
may not be very easy to get so I did
something really naive instead kind of
like the first detector so in this case
I created what I call the windowed Monte
Carlo detector and all we're gonna do is
take two windows of different lengths
one of them longer than the other one
and we're going to Monte Carlo sample
them some amount of times let's say a
thousand which is what I've entered here
and then we're gonna take a look at the
highest density interval on the
difference and we'll say let's say it
defaulted to 95% so was like the 95
percent highest density interval and
we'll see if zero exists on that on that
interval and if it does we can say
confidently that
it's possible the two are the same but
if zero is outside the 95 percent
highest density interval we're going to
say that that's that's different enough
for us to to say that these two
distributions might be different and
will trigger a change so I'm just gonna
write that out now and I'll I'll explain
it I'll just call my second one actually
yeah call his first one Windows Monte
Carlo detector probably didn't even
inherit from change detection on the
last one here no I didn't so in this
case we're gonna need a length for two
different windows so I'm just gonna take
an elect one length to the way and then
we're gonna need a few other small
things like the number of samples that
we're gonna want to we're gonna want to
perform at each time step if you're
doing this in production you might not
even sample at every time step because
it's rather expensive to do and it's
really unnecessary to do it every time
step but since this is small data and
we're running on my local machine or
your local machine we're just gonna go
ahead and do the thing we shouldn't do
anyway we're gonna set a confidence
which in this case is just going to be
the highest density interval and is
everybody familiar with an HDI no okay
so when you're looking at a distribution
the highest density or interval is just
the shortest interval on that
distribution that contains a certain
percentage of the data so when I say the
95% highest density interval I'm talking
about the shortest interval on that
distribution that contains a ninety-five
percent of the data so if you're looking
at you know a perfect bell curve for
example this is just your you know plus
or minus two standard deviations four
ninety five roughly in either direction
that would be that integral and it's a
little more useful on probability masses
which is you know what will be creating
when we Monte Carlo sample the two and
we're just basically saying if we took
the shortest I guess
just 95% of the data is zero in there
somewhere and if it is then we're gonna
assume that the two are the same and
again we're going to take a min samples
because if we have some sort of small
number
we might might generate a false negative
or false positive rather so we're going
to use the same same technique for the
the windows
and what else you need to do oh yeah
record this stuff so record a confidence
and what's that we haven't triggered and
we will also record the number of data
points
so at each step all we're gonna want to
do is feed feed the data point into each
of our two windows and increment our and
and the really fun part about Monte
Carlo sampling is that we get to do
basically just randomly sample a bunch
of a bunch of numbers and we don't
really have to do any sort of detailed
analysis here
so if our n value is greater than our
min samples we're ready to start
analyzing and you'll notice right away
by using this min samples thing we
introduced a bit of a weakness into our
detector if the change occurs way before
the the min samples has occurred we
won't detect it until we've gone through
min samples and I didn't mention it but
we actually saw that earlier when we had
a change occur at 25 and the detector
didn't catch it until 51 because the
detector wasn't even asking the question
if they were different or not until they
got to step 50 so and I didn't record
samples so I'm gonna do that here so
basically we're gonna create a numpy
array of samples diff or sample zeros
which in this case is a thousand and
then a thousand times so we're going to
set the diff to random choice from each
window
and then once that's done we'll take the
highest density interval this is a
function actually at the bottom of the
ipython notebooks so if you haven't I
pulled this out of PI MC so that you
wouldn't have to import it if you
haven't run this last cell here you
might want to go ahead and do that right
so record our HD I'm in HD I max just
going to take the highest density
interval on our newly computed diffs and
we'll use whatever confidence we
specified keep executing it and then
when I want to set our triggered value
if zero is between HD I'm in and HD is
max so again this is the same question I
was asking earlier basically if we take
a histogram of the diffs so the long
window subtracting the shorter window if
zero is on the the 95% highest density
interval we're gonna assume the same if
it's not we're gonna assume they're
different that does not surprise me
there we go thank you
and then if we've triggered we're just
going to set our change point to our end
value
for me
oh right yeah yeah that would that error
would have become really apparent very
quickly we would have triggered right
away pretty much every time let's see
here all right that actually looks
complete so let's see if this one runs
it does okay so I'm just gonna go ahead
and copy this code and we'll just set up
a new detector
winters Monte Carlo detector and we'll
go ahead and we'll use a window of
length let's say 100 and a window of
length 25
stick with a thousands of samples and 95
confidence for now but I'm going to
specify that so we can change it later
it's or 100 500 right and then in the
constructor make sure to set it change
point so that we don't get an error like
that there we go so this technique did
incredibly poorly I don't think it
detected a single change
oh because our generators need to be
reinstated they're not changing
oh that's a really great point that
might have been our problem yeah there
we go so you can see these things are
popping up a lot slower so right here
the first thing to do in step is to add
1 to n instead of set it to zero because
that's not going to do a whole lot for
me
so you know this thing's a lot slower
these things are taking you know a few
seconds each to pop up but with the
correct parameters you can probably get
it to detect a little better I had some
decent parameters for no that's a lovely
sound
under 10,000 oh right yeah yeah the 95%
confidence is kind of a higher
requirement let's lower that there you
go so that might be a bit aggressive but
let's move that to a shorter window it's
still even more aggressive there we go
so with a bit of a hand hunt for
parameters you can already see that that
things are looking a little bit better
for it so now we can put the two against
each other and immediately see the the
first one and I know I've hand-tuned the
parameters for both of these so it's
kind of it's kind of moot you'd want to
do like your grid search or even better
he had a Bayesian parameter search if
you had the time but uh just suggesting
the parameters by hand for a few seconds
gave us root mean squared error of 360
for a threshold detector and 123 for a
Bayesian detector so we've actually
already despite getting a big false
positive here
we've already outperformed our last
technique by a little bit and this
technique is a little bit more
intelligent but it's still fairly naive
and I want to and I better get moving
along here for want to get into it but
um there is a technique and further
research and specifically there was a
great implementation that I linked to
here Bayesian change detection it's
somebody else's ipython notebook on
github it's an implementation of the
technique in the second paper here this
is definitely something if you're
interested in solving this sort of
problem in a real way this is definitely
the paper to check out and for the
remainder here we're just gonna import
the the call volume and we're gonna give
it a shot and see if we can get a
detector so if we get a detector to
detect the exact point which I think was
right around minute 600 that the the
call volume started to increase for this
device I think this might have been the
no I shouldn't call it a specific device
I think I know which device this was I'm
not going to call it out I don't know
what the consequences that could be but
you know probably not good for me so I'm
gonna take our candy remember what I
called it data backed yeah data back
generator I'm gonna feed it the vector
values that I've loaded in from CSV file
and the change point and then create a
detector and a simulator for each and
we'll run the tune we'll see if they're
able to see if each of these would have
been able to find our our call volume
problem
alright so with the default parameters
that we chose in there the looks like
the Montecarlo generator or the
Montecarlo detector detects it almost
straight away eleven minutes late which
would be that'd be great
I guess we just got lucky there with the
parameters that would be great at
Netflix if you could be alerted eleven
minutes after a really low volume device
and I happen to know this is a little
volume device and this is one of the
problems that were attempting itself
here is that sometimes nobody's
streaming on these devices so it's
really sensitive self there's just a
problem or if just nobody's using the
device like I mean we have some there's
some smart TVs that have like ten users
for example that's the type of thing we
detect here looks like the threshold
based detector did a really poor job but
that's because we only asked for 20% of
difference and this is pretty spiky data
so if we move that ups like 120%
difference that looks like it doesn't
even detect it at all at that point but
somewhere in between there is a
parameter that'll probably worked
halfway decently I don't wait it did
let's move that up a little further
let's do it got 200% difference getting
close larger window getting even closer
so yeah it's the type of thing you want
to do a grid search over to determine
you know proper parameters and again tag
data kind of helps here but it's
generally really unavailable especially
in the OP space where I'm working so I
mean I guess I can give everybody some
time to to play around with that while
we do the Q&A if you guys have any more
questions and if not I really highly
recommend checking out the paper and the
implementation here for for a Bayesian
online change point detection cuz it's a
pretty fascinating topic if that's the
sort of thing that you're into
essentially what you're modeling in this
paper and I won't get into explaining
all the details because they're pretty
short on time but effectively and every
point you're modeling the likelihood of
observing a unchanged window of the
length you're at and then the
probability that the current point
you're at now is the the change
detection and I think the really neat
part about Bayesian techniques is that
you do get these human reader
probability is out of them and it's kind
of nice you know for some of these I
mean you know I guess for this you can
say there was a 20% change or you know
we were not confident that the two
distributions were the same based on the
on the difference but the Bayesian
techniques you know you straight-up get
there's an 80% likelihood that this data
point is the point at which it changed
which is very informative for people I
find often times we need to ploy
algorithms like this that's one of the
first things people asked is like and
you know for this it's somewhat simple
but for a lot of like you know more
involved machine learning algorithms
answering why it came to a specific
conclusion is not necessarily an easy
thing to do so with that I'll open up
the Q&A and I'll let people play around
with this a little more and I can come
around and help you if you need help so
so we're answering a bit of a different
question with the two window approach
with the first approach we used well
Ford's method to estimate some summary
statistics for the whole distribution or
for the whole stream up to now for the
multi window approach we're basically
asking does our shorter recent window
look like it was sampled from the same
distribution as our longer window but
again because we're hanging on to data
we only want to hang on to a certain
window worth of data because if you were
to hang on to the whole stream it would
quickly become you know something you'd
want to run on Hadoop and wait an hour
for an answer instead of you know a few
seconds or ideally less far less than a
few seconds yep
yeah yeah we do have some it's not based
on this I think it was a bit much for a
tutorial but uh we have some clustering
based approaches that essentially look
at the relationship between two
variables and when that relationship
behaves differently than you would
expect it to so in that case when two
variables that are normally correlated
or anti-correlated behave in the
complete opposite manner you would learn
on that sort of thing
so for something like this for
techniques that are simple as the ones
that we're using right now you would
essentially have to use window lengths
that included your your weekends and
whatnot which again weakened it against
detecting subtle subtle changes because
I said I would put it let's say you're
measuring error rates which would let's
say naturally be higher on a weekend
because you have more traffic if you get
a higher error if you do this and then
you get a higher error rate on a weekday
you might not detect it because you're
your model is now modeling a broader
distribution so that's certainly a
drawback to both approaches that we've
taken here yep
yeah that that's um there's a couple
different solutions so that sort of
thing
normalizing is certainly one of them and
and generally speaking on mostly metrics
we analyze internally in Netflix we will
normalize them by requests per second
that the server's taking or something
like that and you know some metric that
the metric you're looking at is
dependent upon but sometimes or at least
one of the really popular ones we use
the Netflix is stream stream starts per
second and that's not dependent on
anything so that one's tough to analyze
and that's that is one that we actually
analyze change on for devices as well
anomaly detection tends to work better
there because we can't normalize it
all right well if there are any more
questions I guess I'll just I'll wrap it
up but I'll stick around until whenever
this is supposed to end five five ten
I think five twenty and I'll help
anybody out that needs any help thanks
for sticking around